today we're going to be speaking with
Jeffrey Mandel who's President and Lead
counsel at law forward the firm that
filed the landmark lawsuit against the
fraudulent 2020 electors in Wisconsin uh
really great having you on I appreciate
your time
thanks so much David it's great to be
here so just to get everybody kind of up
to speed we saw attempts at this fake
elector scam in a number of different
states Arizona is one place where it
made a lot of news the concept was even
though Joe Biden won what if we we
meaning typically some Republicans what
if we just send Republican electors to
say we're giving our electoral votes to
Donald Trump anyway that's the gist of
it is that right
that is the gist of it it requires us
stepping back and sort of thinking back
to Schoolhouse Rock and our basic
understanding of students we all think
that every fourth November we go to the
polls and we vote for a candidate for
president right people say did you vote
for Biden or did you vote for Trump but
in reality you're voting for a slate of
electors who will represent your state
in the Electoral College it is not the
popular vote it is that Electoral
College vote that chooses the president
and so what we had was seven states
where even though the popular vote said
that the electors pledged to Joe Biden
and Kamala Harris would represent that
state in the Electoral College
nonetheless electors who were pledged to
Donald Trump and Mike Pence chose to
meet and submit papers claiming that
they were actually the valid qualified
and duly elected electors for their
state so in Wisconsin for example what
that meant was we had 10 individuals and
as you know they're mostly Republican
party bigwigs who decided that they knew
better than 3.3 million of their
neighbors a record 3.3 million
wisconsinites voted in 2020 and these 10
people decided that they didn't care
what those other 3.3 million people
thought they were going to take it upon
themselves to hijack Wisconsin's
participation in choosing the next
president
now when we talk about the January 6th
committee there's an investigation
happening in Georgia Etc the question of
criminality of some of the different
things that were attempted is is often
brought up to be clear you have filed a
lawsuit that seeks damages the
criminality question is a different one
when it comes to these schemes is that
right
that's right and I do think that uh at
least here under Wisconsin state law and
around the country under federal law I
think that there is a likelihood that
many of these people committed crimes
and could be prosecuted and potentially
uh put in jail but what we're filing is
a civil lawsuit that seeks civil
remedies
um and will be a way of trying to learn
more about exactly what did happen here
in Wisconsin and how it worked because a
civil lawsuit comes with Discovery the
opportunity to see documents to take
depositions and have testimony I'm
trying to think back you know there was
this kind of circus tour that went
around the country that involved Rudy
Giuliani and Jenna Ellis and sometimes
Sydney Powell and others did did that
circus go through Wisconsin around the
same time that the fake elector scam was
being kind of conceived
well the circus never came fully to town
here in Wisconsin
um you know Rudy Giuliani for example to
my knowledge never came uh to Wisconsin
we did have one of Sydney Powell's uh
Kraken lawsuits yes mainstream
conspiracy theories here in Wisconsin
and what's interesting about that I mean
there are lots of things that are
interesting about that but one of the
things that's interesting about that is
the plaintiff that Sydney Powell
represented in that lawsuit is one of
the fraudulent electors right
um here in Wisconsin so all of this is
tied together and so the circus came to
town through the courts but it never
came to town with the with the full
media Entourage so in terms of your
lawsuit I mean what are you alleging
what are the damages who who was uh
damaged so to speak
sure so we represent um three plaintiffs
two of them were actually the among the
valid electors for Joe Biden and Kamala
Harris okay one of them is a voter who
feels strongly that these people tried
to disenfranchise her and steal the
value of her vote by going against the
will of the voters and what we're doing
is we're using some old established
common law ideas to try to get at this
conduct fundamentally the problem is
nobody ever thought that someone would
try something as audacious as what these
fake electors did in these seven states
so there is no law that says you can't
do that because we don't pass laws that
tell people not to do things that nobody
would ever imagine someone would do and
that has led to this challenge of saying
no matter who we talk to when we explain
what the fraudulent electors did
everyone says oh that can't be right
that can't be legal
um that offends my most basic sense of
fair play and Civic understanding of
democracy right but there isn't a
specific law so what we've done is we've
taken some very old principles from the
common law and said that we think that
these fit so one of them is public
nuisance right our election system and
our democracy is a finely calibrated and
and somewhat fragile structure that is
for the public good and there is a
long-standing idea that if if if I take
private action that harms the public
good
um someone can try to stop me using an
adoption that says that I'm creating a
nuisance to the public for my own
benefit but everyone else is detriment
so we're using that theory uh we're
using a theory of civil conspiracy that
these is 10 electors and thus far we've
also named two lawyers who assisted them
and we might need to add more people as
as we find out who else was involved
right the January 6 committee recently
made quite clear that Senator Johnson
seems to be involved
um but that these people conspired
to break the law whether they ultimately
did break the law right that's sort of
the criminal question but the fact that
they were trying to break the law that
they were trying to convince Congress
to take these papers that in itself we
think is actionable and there is a long
long standing idea
um and I apologize for the Latin but it
goes under the name of
this is a red an order that you could go
to for hundreds of years to courts if
you were supposed to serve in a public
office but someone else was occupying
that office and keeping you out of it
and so we are bringing a a a claim for
such an order on behalf of the actual
electors that these other people have
tried to usurp that office and by saying
we Trump fraudulent electors we're the
real electors they are implicitly saying
that the Biden electors are liars and
are are not the real electors and so
we're also bringing a claim under under
that here have the um have the have the
fraudulent electors had to personally
lawyer up as a result of this at this
point
they have so um they've all hired
Council and we're in those early stages
of lawsuits as you know David you know
litigation can be kind of slow yes so
we're in the early stages of the the
lawyer sort of maneuvering we filed in
State Court they would rather be federal
court which is not where this case
belongs and so we're in the process of
bringing it back to State Court what
kind of uh damages and restitution are
you seeking here
so we're seeking a number of things um
first we're seeking a clear and uh
unambiguous order from a court that what
happened here was improper and unlawful
and it should never happen again
second we are seeking an order that
would prohibit any of these people from
ever being involved with the Electoral
College in Wisconsin again because it
seems to me that they have abused the
privilege of being part of our Civic
Fabric and they should they should not
have that opportunity again I agree um
third
we are seeking
um deterrence we want accountability and
we want deterrence we never want to see
this happen again and so we are seeking
punitive damages for the fact that these
folks um deliberately interfered in the
legal rights of the real electors and
under Wisconsin law those punitive
damages could be up to 200 000 for each
of the defendants have you been in touch
with potential uh with lawyers that are
potentially looking at doing this in
other states where these schemes were
hatched
we've certainly uh We've certainly had
some conversations and some Outreach it
is my hope I really believe that both
accountability and deterrence are
essential so this doesn't happen again
and so it is my hope that we will see uh
cases like this in all of the states one
of the big questions is if whoever had
followed through on this like if these
electors had gotten on a plane or you
know what whatever the the real attempt
was a bona fide attempt what would have
happened like could could they have said
no we we believe that Trump gets these
votes and then what would have happened
I mean John Eastman wrote this memo of
how what Pence could do he's now in
legal Jeopardy himself he's had to
lawyer up the FBI recently sees this
phone you know he's got his fair share
of problems for even suggesting this
framework but there's this question of
like if they both show up then then what
would have happened
well I mean the reality is we came a lot
closer to that than than we'd like to
think because I think your intuition
that the Electoral College happens in
Washington is a common one but that's
actually not right
the Electoral College happens in each
state's capital at the same time on the
same date and so when these fraudulent
electors met in Madison on December 14th
of 2020 and they and they signed these
papers claiming to be the real electors
and when that happened in Arizona and in
Georgia and in Michigan and in Nevada
and in Pennsylvania and in New Mexico
that that was the thing they submitted
these papers that's the act in other
words like the real electors did it on
that day and the fake electors did and
then so at that point it's it's it but
they've both done it
that's absolutely right and it really
all came down to to then vice president
Pence
um if he had followed John Eastman's uh
wishes and been willing to credit those
votes then we would have seen um chaos
we would have seen how Congress reacted
uh we've seen uh almost certainly
litigation but we really would have been
in a constitutional crisis
um it is to uh to to Mr Pence's credit
that he refused to go along with that
and recognize that uh in our in our
democracy the will of the voters really
is sacrosanct yet Thom Hartmann radio
host Tom Hartman has an interesting
Twitter thread from in the last week it
might be a few days ago were he kind of
outlines
what this could look like in 2024 with
the difference that there is a move to
accept different electors and that
although we all intuitively know that's
not right it's not what's supposed to
happen it would be a violation of the
will of the people all of the things
that you've said it's not so cut and dry
that it obviously fails that it could
get pretty complicated and dicey for a
period of time
it absolutely could and one of the ways
that that could happen is if state
courts that um support the losing
candidate wanted to
um sort of Muddy the waters in in
Wisconsin for example the we had a
partial recount or president Trump's
campaign asked for a recount in in the
Madison area in Milwaukee and then when
they didn't like the results of that
recount because it actually showed that
that Biden won by more votes
um they they they filed a lawsuit as
they're entitled to do to challenge the
results of the recount and that case
went up to the Wisconsin Supreme Court
the Wisconsin Supreme Court took
unprecedented actions I don't think this
had ever happened before the case came
in on a Friday afternoon the Electoral
College was meeting on Monday at noon
and that's a statutory deadline
and so the court had people brief late
at night on Friday night they held oral
argument by zoom on Saturday and they
issued a full opinion
um with all of its reasoning and
everything on Monday morning so that
they would have given the final word on
the election results in Wisconsin before
the Electoral College met but imagine I
mean Mr Eastman's arguments would be
much stronger if the court had not done
that if there was still a question about
who the legal winner in a state was
right then there is a much better
argument for these dueling slates and
you really have questions then about how
Congress is supposed to resolve this or
what they're supposed to do so we could
with what we've learned from 2020 we
could imagine in 2024 a number of actors
uh taking making specific decisions to
try to uh leave more flexibility for
Congress or the vice president or make
this uglier and harder in ways that are
really really
um dangerous to our democracy very very
scary but uh one piece of what what is
being done uh is this lawsuit and we've
been speaking with Jeffrey Mandel
president and Lead counsel at law
forward thanks so much for talking to me
today and explaining what you're what
you're doing
thanks David for having me it's a
pleasure I appreciate your attention to
this and I hope we can come back and
update you as it moves forward